just a quick reminder SuperSpeed I don't
have it
noted direct from earth do you like my
face
it's the face you were wearing when I
became the flesh I thought I'd put it on
again
you know for old times sake Plus just
want to remind you of one thing
SuperSpeed I don't have it probably two
of the best hours we've seen from DC TV
so just careful for spoilers for parts 1
& 2 of the crossover this will be for
the first two episodes the second half
of the crossover is happening tomorrow
night so I'll do the video the same way
tomorrow too and there is a new round at
that flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a flash related comment on the video it
was a lot of stuff we knew about this
going into it but still a couple really
huge surprises in a couple things that
were Loki confirmed without actually
legit making it official so I'll try to
explain because I do believe that we got
one of the tornado twins but we pick up
with a twist on all of our taking down
in operation it's Earth X Oliver taking
down the resistance and it turns out
Guardian is part of that he has an
American flag painted on his shield like
he did briefly during the comics
Guardians had a couple of different
costumes but he's not a huge character
so he hasn't popped up that much but
they do brand new intros for each of the
shows in a sort of roll call going
through each of the characters just
touching base on the RSVP for the
wedding like hey are we going to the
wedding and then they jump to another
show are we going to the wedding
we get to see flash take down King shark
in short order showing you just how much
more powerful he's gotten all of us
fighting nameless ninjas the legends are
doing Robin Hood heatwave is little John
Martin Stein as Friar Tuck supergirls
fighting a Dominator they name-drop
hellgrammite who's actually this bug
character from The Brave and the bold
volume 1 number 80 The Brave and the
bold was the name of the first time the
flash and arrow crossed over a couple
years ago it was actually flash versus
arrow then braving the bolt was the
second part but Supergirl uses the
portal they gave her last season to
bring them to earth 1 because
everybody's coming for the wedding so
they all arrive at the same time you can
tell that they spent a lot more money on
the CG so they can like show them both
portaling in at the same time they lay a
little bit of track for iris West
tornado twins with Barry when they're
all sitting there talking drinking
champagne getting their nails
done and she's like I'm totally not
ready for children so later in the
episode at the wedding
this actress comes up and she's like
this mystery caterer
but she's from black sails she's
actually a pretty big actress has this
really funny moment with Barry where
she's like I'm so excited to be here
like she's never been more happy to see
something go down and she just reminds
Barry make sure you say I do so the
rumor going into this is that she was
going to be playing something really
special and even though they didn't say
what her name is she sort of disappears
in the action but the idea is that she's
probably going to be Don West and she
secretly traveled back in time to watch
her parents get married they just seem
to be laying the groundwork on the flash
for Iris and Barry's children to come or
be featured on the show in some way
either this season or in a future season
team flash is going to help firestorm
separate but it will mean them losing
their powers and you get all these
spider-man Easter eggs when Martin Stein
tries to change Jax's genome like I have
a new serum that's going to give you
powers and you'll be able to still be a
legend are you trying to turn me into
spider-man will I have spidey sense a
whole bunch of DC TV Marvel references
this season you may have recognized this
Nazi scientist he didn't really get a
name in the episode but he played the
eye on Legion who was a villain he just
looks really scary so of course he'd be
great Nazi you get some nice Ronnie
references when Martin Stein and Caitlin
are together the last wedding I was at
was your wedding back during season 1
funny how many season 1 references there
were during this episode particularly
the reverse-flash one the big reveal
that he's eobard thawne the reference
goes a little bit deeper when you find
out that martin stein named his grandson
ronnie and he'll probably wind up being
the other half of firestorm in the
future but you get all the jokes from
the wedding they have this runner with
heat wave and killer frost where he
seems really excited by her didn't I try
and pick you up once Leena keeps trying
to turn her into killer frost like
heatwave and killer frost like Captain
Cold used to be his buddy in the past
and he just really likes the idea of
pairing up with someone who looks really
hot and has ice powers they totally went
for the Alex Cera low-hanging fruit just
give me all your orange is the new black
memes there's a great joke about
Supergirl floating in mid-air asleep in
her sleeping bag
but I love how they sit him next to all
the law enforcement officials like well
I've tried to kill the groom a couple
times in the past so you better sit me
on that side so he sits next to captain
Singh who doesn't immediately recognize
him as one of the Rogues they referenced
the musical episode from last season
when berries like that special new power
that you have the song she sings is the
original song that they wrote for that
episode that he sang to Iris running
home to you not a hundred percent on
this but I think that the minister
that's performing the ceremony is
William Katt from The Greatest American
Hero
and then obviously they get to the point
where someone objects that person is
over a girl and they have the Nazi
invasion they do the Indiana Jones line
Nazis I hate those guys
the fight was great they find ways of
pairing the characters up like they do a
couple scenes with heat wave and killer
frost fighting people together she has
this really cool ice Lance that she
forms she even jokes about how she hates
pink again that's a big killer frost
thing like oh god why does Caitlin like
pink so much this is terrible they
finally capture Earth X Prometheus and
sure enough this is probably the most
spoilery thing about the episode they
totally went for the Tommy thing and
it's this great scene that you've been
waiting for since the end of season one
like Oliver has not had a chance to have
it out with Tommy's since he died
there's been no alternate version of him
since then and they do this really great
thing where Tommy appeals to him he has
the same relationship with his version
of Oliver on earth X I would have died
for him I would have died for you too
but you did it first on my earth and
then you get a perma theus level twist
when he gets all psycho and you see that
he's totally drunk Third Reich kool-aid
and you learned that he's the one that
had that line from the trailer everyone
you love everyone you care about they're
all going to die so Oliver gets to watch
Tommy die a second time but they end
with the reveal of the Blitz and flash
over girl and evil Oliver team-up this
was mostly a face reveal like oh this is
who the villains they're facing are
going to be but we knew that going into
this they'd already released all those
pictures blitz and flash totally hates
Oliver Oliver totally hates blitz and
flash they're ready to kill each other
we had a pretty good idea that Oliver
was gonna be with over girl on this
earth there was a teaser during a panel
that Stephen Amell did a while ago and
talked about a passionate kiss that he
shared with Cara but they didn't say
which version so it's like oh it's
probably evil Cara and evil Oliver
they're probably in a relationship but
the really cool thing I felt like they
did with their relationship is that they
actually had some really great scenes
together so you do believe it through
the power of their performance that they
really care about each other we get a
Brainiac reference from iris and then
you get everybody rolling out like a new
suit up montage as they all go out and
Oliver gets to do the Batman thing where
he swings on the ripcord it's like right
out of Justice League it's like there's
an arc of Lightning behind Batman in
this version but probably the funniest
line from the entire crossover so far is
when Oliver rolls in and they're getting
ready to face their counterparts and
says I just want to remind you of one
thing
SuperSpeed I don't have it then you meet
the Blitzen flash he reveals what his
backstory is eobard thawne but what
happened on Earth X is is that we learn
that the Nazis developed the bomb before
the Allied powers and that's how they
won the war they kind of implied that
their version of the reverse flash came
back in time gave the Nazis the bomb
during World War two because he's a time
traveler he can go anywhere he wants in
time and then that's how they won so the
reverse flash is responsible for
precipitating what happened on earth X
but you may have missed this really
special line that he had at the end of
the episode where he talks to Barry and
says all the times that you killed me I
only have to kill you once on this earth
we learned over girls backstory is
basically red Sun but she also has some
all-star Superman thrown in there too so
during red Sun Superman's pod lands in
the Soviet Union
so communists take over the entire earth
the same thing happened with over girl
except she landed in Germany so it's a
red Sun story but her character art is
from the all-star Superman comic she's
absorbed too much solar radiation they
need to drain it off or it's going to
kill her but they have a lot of
kryptonite arrow references they're all
surprised to learn that Oliver has been
keeping them on the DL he's been
shopping at the Kryptonite sporting
goods store Barry makes a lot of jokes
about time travel when Cara's talking
about the Legion of super-heroes
she says you know all kinds of time
travel Mon L craziness is going on in
Barry's like yeah I know all about time
travel just referencing Savitt are in
the events of season
we get to see metallo come back for the
first time since the beginning of
Supergirl season 2 we also got red
tornado on the poster so it's implied
that he'll show up sometime in the next
two episodes too but let me know if you
spotted any Easter eggs that I didn't
mention in the video and let me know
what was your favorite part I feel like
the tommy reveal was probably the
biggest one the first two episodes but
what'll happen is I'll post another
bonus video tomorrow before the second
part of the crossover starts but I'll do
a similar Easter Egg video for that win
at post but there is that new round of
the flash ring giveaway I'll just
announce the winner when I post that
trailer video tomorrow morning so you
can click here for a brand new infinity
war and you can click here for more
crossover thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight